- Avec nous, Charlotte Gainsbourg.
Bienvenue.
Je comprends que ayez le trac,
car ce n'est pas facile.
C'est plus difficile
de venir ici, au journal télévisé,
ou de tourner un film
avec Claude Miller ?
- De venir ici.
- C'est plus difficile
de venir ici ?
Qu'est-ce que c'est
qu'une petite fille effrontée,
dans le film ?
- C'est une fille qui...
C'est dur à dire, parce que...
- C'est une petite fille
qui voit une autre petite fille
qui représente pour elle tout
ce qu'elle voudrait être, non ?
- Oui.
Mais...
C'est dur, parce qu'il faut
regrouper tout le titre du film,
toute l'histoire en même temps.
- En un seul mot, c'est sûr.
Je voulais vous poser une question,
parce que votre mère,
elle chante, elle fait du cinéma,
elle fait du théâtre. Votre père
fait de la musique, il écrit aussi.
Alors vous, vous avez envie
de vous diriger vers le cinéma ?
- Je ne sais pas.
- Là,
le cinéma, vous aimez bien ça,
en tout cas.
- Oui, mais je ne sais pas.
- Quand on chante avec son papa,
c'est difficile ou facile ?
- Ben, c'est...
Ni l'un, ni l'autre, c'est...
Quand j'ai fais ça,
je ne me suis pas posée la question,
j'ai fais ça pour lui,
pour être avec lui.
- Quand il vous a demandé,
vous n'avez pas dis non ?
- Non, il n'y avait pas à dire non.
- Quand Claude Miller vous a proposé
de tourner dans "L'Effrontée",
vous aviez déjà fait
"Paroles et musiques".
Mais quand on vous propose un film,
vous lisez l'histoire,
vous dites oui tout de suite,
vous demandez conseille à Jane ?
- J'étais en Suisse,
alors j'étais un peu loin.
Et ils en ont parlé entres eux
avec Claude et mes parents.
- D'abord ?
Avant de demander votre avis ?
- Oui, parce que
c'était un peu...
Il ne voulait pas me prévenir,
car comme ils étaient
pas sûrs de le faire,
il ne voulait pas
me faire une fausse joie.
- C'est ainsi que ça s'est passé ?
- Tout à fait.
Il fallait que je demande
d'abord aux parents.
C'est la moindre des choses.
Et c'est vrai
que quand je leur ai parlé
de ce projet,
on n'était pas sûr, financièrement,
de réussir à le monter.
Alors, on a préféré la prévenir
à la dernière minute.
- Vous avez dans cette histoire
3 petites filles.
Charlotte a une petite copine
avec qui elle a presque des rapports
conjugaux, on se dispute,
on se réconcilie,
on ne se quitte pas.
Et soudain, elle découvre une petite
fille fabuleuse qui est concertiste.
Et elle est prête
à quitter son milieu
pour la suivre.
On verra bien la suite
en ayant voir le film.
Pour trouver
vos trois petites filles,
vous avez dû passé votre temps
à faire la sortie des écoles.
- Pas du tout.
Charlotte Gainsbourg, je l'ai
trouvée grâce à Elie Chouraqui
en voyant "Paroles et musiques".
J'avais écrit la moitié du scénario
quand j'ai vu ce film.
Pour moi c'était évident
que ça allait être elle.
Il fallait que ça soit elle.
Ma seule angoisse, c'est que
les parents ne soient pas d'accord.
Ca s'est bien passé de ce côté là.
Et celle qui fait
la petite concertiste,
il faut dire qu'elle ne connaît pas
une note de musique,
c'est une lycéenne, comme Charlotte,
et il se trouve qu'elle a un prof
de français qui adore le cinéma.
Et tous les ans, il prend
un garçon et une fille
et fait un remake en vidéo de
"La Drôlesse" de Jacques Doillon.
J'étais au courant
de cette histoire.
J'ai vu les différents films
de ces deux dernières années,
et on a trouvé Clothilde Baudon.
- Claude Miller,
on a l'impression que vous faites
petit à petit une oeuvre.
Vous faites un parcours
sans faute dans vos films.
- Ca me fais plaisir
ce que vous me dites,
mais c'est à vous,
au public, au critique d'en parler.
Chaque film doit être une garantie
de plaisir de travail pour moi.
Je ne me rends pas compte si il y a
une continuité dans tout ça.
- Merci, Claude Miller.
Merci, Charlotte Gainsbourg.
Je rappelle le titre
de votre film, "L'Effrontée".
France Roche a beaucoup aimé.